[Music]
chaos had erupted all hell had broken
loose and Nightmares were running amok
even from her perspective watching as
fleshy Abominations tore through the
streets of New York City Eliza Flynn
couldn't escape the feeling that the
entire world had gone mad only moments
before things had been calm normal
another mundane uninteresting day in the
Big Apple now she was watching in horror
from underneath an overturned table as a
group of things had seemingly appeared
out of nowhere unbeknownst to Eliza
these creatures were instances of
something known as scp-610 alternatively
going by the name the flesh that hates
from her hiding place inside the local
coffee shop she frequented they looked
like horrific mutated masses of Flesh
that barely resembled anything even
close to human but that's what they were
or at least had been Eliza had witnessed
a barista rushing out into the street
trying to get away from a group of
scp-610s that were bashing their
appendages against the front window in
trying to make a break for it the
mutated creatures attacked the Barista
killing him upon making contact with his
skin it was only a short while
afterwards that Eliza spotted his body
moving the Infectious process only
accelerated by the heat from a nearby
car that was on fire before long what
had once been a barista an ordinary
person was now another of the grotesque
flesh monsters Mike she remembered his
name had been Mike she'd read it on his
name tag when she came in for her
morning coffee he had always smiled
never got the spelling of her name right
on her to-go cup riding it with an S
instead of a z and now he was gone worse
than dead he wasn't even Mike anymore
instead turned into another scp-610
monstrosity too petrified to move
terrified of being caught and turned
into another of those fleshy nightmares
Eliza stayed hidden this was it she
thought to herself any moment now one of
those things would find her either
breaking through the street-facing
window of the coffee shop or slithering
in through the rear fire door sure
enough the flesh formerly known as Mike
the Barista turned where had once there
been a head was now a featureless blob
that had fused with the shoulder but
Eliza could tell its eyelasterra was
being directed at her and she had
nowhere to run Mike's arm which was now
a slimy blood red tentacle began
slamming against the glass cracks
forming across the surface Eliza's eyes
darted around the room trying to look
for some kind of way out her options
were limited and even then they didn't
amount to more than hiding in a storage
cupboard and prolonging the inevitable
she needed a miracle as if to answer her
prayers a blinding white light erupted
from somewhere out of view beyond the
window Turning Away Eliza had to Shield
her eyes from the Searing glow blinking
away spots in her vision as she looked
to see what had happened the scp-610
creature Mike had vanished a dark
outline scorched against the glass as if
it had been obliterated by an intense
focused blast that light whatever it was
had vaporized it the sound of commotion
came bustling through the door a
distorted mechanical sounding voices
called out hello is anyone there hello
is anyone in here one garbled we mean
you no harm another said but you need to
leave this place as soon as you can
cautiously Eliza stood up from under the
table standing at the entrance to the
coffee shop were a trio of figures each
one of them had Machinery all manner of
metallic components protruding from
their bodies replacing arms legs parts
of their faces Eliza stared at them
unsure whether these cyborgs were as
harmless as they claimed one even had a
cannon in place of one of their hands
which was still smoking from the blast
that had killed the scp-610 instances
outside did the flush make contact with
you one of the figures asked no Eliza
replied that's how they spread right
it's like an infection I watched it
happen indeed the cyborg with the Canon
arm replied The Flash being loose is
only the beginning if you are uninfected
then we'd ask you to come with us we'll
explain on the way hang on who are you
Eliza ass concern on her face and where
are you taking me we are the Church of
the broken God one of them answered and
we're getting you out of New York the
idea of a person making their way out of
the city that never sleeps on foot would
be laughable to anyone that lived there
even before it had become overrun with
monsters but the subway wasn't exactly
running on time and the roads were
gridlocked with cars that had either
been destroyed or abandoned by their
owners so walking out of New York was
the the only option the Church of the
broken God cyborgs explained to Eliza as
much as they knew about what had
happened they described an organization
a secret cabal with power spanning the
entire world called the SCP Foundation
apparently this Foundation had been
responsible for Gathering and
safeguarding the world from dangerous
and unexplained phenomena you mean like
those flesh things she asked exactly
they called those
scp-610 but recently something had
changed the foundation had turned its
seemingly inexhaustible resources to the
goal of Exterminating Humanity it was by
their hands that instances of scp-610
had been Unleashed in major cities not
just New York but Delhi Tokyo London and
countless others those were far from the
only anomalies the foundation had
deployed either as they walked the
cyborgs described how someone called Mr
Deeds had been assassinating heads of
state the world over they also spelled
spoke of a horrifying reptile that was
now running wild and slaughtering
everything in its path we at the church
had to act whatever the foundation's
reasons for unleashing this hell we
couldn't sit by and allow them to
destroy everything so we've aligned
ourselves with the global occult
coalition to assist them in fighting
against the flesh that hates in exchange
we have vowed to help transport
survivors to safety but where can we
possibly go that's safe Eliza
interjected If the foundation had the
reach you say they do if they have all
these horrible creatures at their
disposal what chance do we have at
surviving well there is always our path
one of the broken God's followers
replied the path of standardization
becoming one with machine on mechanized
pods are safe from the flesh's
corruption if you would consider joining
us Eliza took a quick glance at the
metallic components of Earth cyborg
companions they look like they heard as
much as becoming a scp-610 monster would
have she politely declined although it
led to the rest of their Journey
continuing in an awkward silence
eventually the broken God cyborgs
brought Eliza to an extraction point
where they left her in the care of the
global occults Coalition boarding a
convoy her and a number of others were
ferried out of New York state by the GOC
for the first time since this had all
started Eliza started to think that
maybe she was heading to somewhere safe
that sliver of hope all Came Crashing
Down the moment the Convoy was attacked
armed assailants opened fire on the
trucks they were quickly identified by
Coalition soldiers as members of the SCP
foundation's mobile task forces Special
Operations troops sent out to pick off
survivors in the midst of the fire fight
gunfire erupting all around her Eliza
never felt so terrified one of the GOC
officers turned to her as they crouched
behind cover listen I shouldn't be
telling you this but there's rumors of a
Survivor settlement not far from here He
barked I'll draw their fire you run get
as far away from here fast as you can
and don't look back doing as she was
told Eliza sprinted away from the
wreckage of the Convoy until her legs
refused to run any further she trudged
alone through an empty Town abandoned it
felt like a place out of a nightmare the
world was decimated virtually
post-apocalyptic the further she willed
herself to walk the more she could feel
herself giving up that she would never
even find the settlement if it even
existed at all Pope had abandoned her
and at her lowest point Eliza dug her
heels in and dropped to the ground both
exhausted and convinced she'd been
hiking towards nothing the feeling of
being moved caused Eliza to stir waking
her up from a dream that had been almost
as Bleak as her new reality someone was
carrying her on what felt like a
stretcher she quickly realized before
she had a chance to ask who they were
the pair of shadowy human shapes brought
her through the woods to what looked
like a campsite don't be alarmed one of
them said in a voice that sounded so
optimistic it felt almost alien as if
this person was from another planet
where things were far less horrible
looking around Eliza noticed the glow of
a campfire Illuminating the nearby trees
a handful of people were huddled
together in makeshift tents resting and
wearing contented almost Happy
Expressions then Eliza's eyes were drawn
towards something else some slimy Mass
gliding around the camp at first she
thought it was another instance of
scp-610 until she saw an amorphous
gelatinous orange blob glowing in the
Fire Light to the foundation it had been
known as scp-999 but to its Newfound
family of human survivors this creature
was their savior a Bastion of Hope and
happiness in a devastated hellscape the
Tickle Monster welcomed into the
Survivor Community with open arms Eliza
was soon exposed to
scp-9999's anomalous effects the
creature seemed to warm to her instantly
greeting her with the enthusiastic
friendliness of a small dog even after
as little as a single interaction with
it she felt her lack of Hope and
depressed feelings towards the bleakness
of the world had almost entirely faded
she felt happiness pure genuine
happiness for the first time in recent
memory thanks to the Tickle Monster
Eliza's entire Outlook had completely
changed the same was true for the other
survivors that had formed a settlement
around the happy orange creature they
had all come seeking an escape not just
a physical place that was out of Harm's
Way but somewhere they could reject the
harsh reality of what the SCP Foundation
had done to the world and scp-999 had
provided that for them all curing the
displaced refugees of their woes keeping
them in perpetually High Spirits most of
them had reached such a point of
contentment that they'd forgotten their
old lives before the collapse before the
anomalies and the foundation although
the Tickle Monster demanded nothing of
its new found family apart from the
occasional playful tickle wrestle Eliza
and a group of the other survivors would
venture back to the nearby abandoned
town just beyond the woods once there
they would scavenge for as much food as
they could find keeping a close eye out
for any candy with which to feed scp-999
even though they knew 999 was more than
happy to provide positivity to the
survivors each one of them felt it was
the least they could do for their
favorite orange slime ball there was
such a continuous state of love and
happiness in their camp that the
survivors were hardly phased when a
foundation Soldier inadvertently
stumbled upon their settlement before he
could raise his weapon and fire
scp-999 slid between its friends and the
soldier blocking the path of his bullets
without any shred of malice or hostility
the delightful blob leaped towards the
attacking MTF operative and embraced him
instantly the foundation foot soldiers
demeanor changed before he had been
glassy eyed motionless like something
deep inside him had broken but after
their hug parted the man was euphoric
grinning in a state of elation for long
afterwards for a Time Eliza sat with the
soldier Sergeant Kalos and listened to
him explaining how he wanted to renounce
the foundation to stay with this
community of survivors now he knew as CP
999 was here do you remember anything
from before she asked curiously before
Kalos echoed you mean before the
foundation did all this Eliza nodded
remembering the outside world was hazy
Now by trying to recall the vague
details of a dream not much the former
MTF Trooper answered they wanted us to
to kill everyone because of it what like
the Stephen King book no
Kalos chuckled they told us it had
latched itself on to everyone All Humans
of Consciousness it had plans something
really really awful So the foundation's
plan was to wipe everyone out wouldn't
that include everyone who works for the
foundation no they um
altered us made it so we couldn't feel
pain anymore he paused and began
giggling uncontrollably as if he had
just understood the punch line to a joke
in fact Kalos said between fits of
laughter that's probably how 999 was
able to fix me next to him Eliza
couldn't help but laugh too the humor
was infectious because you couldn't feel
pain she giggled yeah yeah callous
exploded delighted tears rolling down
his face I
I'm for it I was hollowed out and that
would have made it easy for scp-999 to
fill that space with this
he rolled over onto the floor still
chortling unstoppably and this didn't
stop for hours the tickle Monster's
powers of positivity had increased
exponentially since it had found itself
free from the foundation facility it had
used to live at much like callow had
explained to Eliza it had allowed The
Lovable blob to correct the alteration
the foundation had made to the former
MTF Sergeant allowing him to feel
Euphoria in the place of his total
absence of all pain and now thanks to
the influence of scp-999 the threat
posed by both the SCP Foundation and
whatever this it entity was seems so far
away so irrelevant and did little to
dampen the High Spirits of the survivors
in the camp but in their Collective
sense of bliss Eliza scp-999 and the
other survivors became a little
oblivious to the outside world and its
Horrors little did they know there was
still danger lurking much closer than
they realized one that had spread from
miles away and would very soon be at the
settlement it was Eliza and callow that
first discovered what was lurking nearby
they had both been searching for food in
the ruins of the Old Town beyond the
woods which felt more and more like a
completely different world the longer
they spent in the camp with scp-999 as
Eliza rummaged through the storeroom of
an abandoned Supermarket she heard a
scream of Agony coming from nearby
callow for the first time in months
Panic fear and adrenaline rocked her
system it almost made her feel sick she
had been so overloaded with positive
endorphins that it had practically
numbed her to all other feelings but
Instinct kicked in fight or flight
hitting her with the force of an ice
cold bucket of water and she ran out
into the store to look for callow what
she saw gave her a terrified knot in her
stomach the kind she hadn't felt since
the day the nightmare had started the
flesh that hates an instance of scp-610
was standing in the aisles of the empty
Supermarket the site of the grotesque
mutated form shuffling towards her made
Eliza freeze on the spot it took a
further moment to realize that callow
had long since stopped screaming Eliza's
thoughts had picked up speed for the
first time in months she was processing
information without it being dulled by
the Euphoria brought on by scp-999 it
made her realize that this scp-610 had
either killed callow and he'd soon be
turning into one of those flesh
creatures for this was callow and he'd
already changed Thinking Fast Eliza
sprinted through the supermarket hearing
the snarls of the flesh coming after her
she passed a shopping cart and in an
instance grabbed its handlebar turning
the metal cage around and racing full
force towards the scp-610 instance
chasing her the card collided with the
blood red mass of the flesh the sheer
force knocking the creature onto its
back and giving Eliza a window of
opportunity to race out of the
supermarket watched by a gaggle of
mutated creatures those of them that
still had eyes followed her movements as
she ran back towards the woods toward
the camp and slowly the flesh that hates
began to fall out from the moment that
she returned to the settlement scp-999
could immediately sense that Eliza was
in a state of panic instinctively the
creature glided up to her only seeking
to comfort her and make her forget about
whatever had troubled her no stop she
protested as much as she wanted to not
worry about the impending danger
scp-999 recalled from her a wounded
expression on its gooey orange face I'm
sorry it's just we're all in serious
trouble Eliza urged the other survivors
gathered around lazily each of them
seeming upbeat despite her grave news
the flesh scp-610 they're here they
found us she explained they killed
callow and it won't take them long to
find us they won't come here one of the
survivors replied not argumentatively
but in a more uplifting and reassuring
tone none of the other anomalies offend
Us in months another interjected smiling
not even the foundation can get us here
we're protected the Tickle Monster keeps
us all safe but what if it can't protect
us from the flesh Eliza desperately
tried to warn her fellow survivors but
they were in too much of a Carefree
state to fear the approach of the flesh
that hates a number of them tried to
convince her to relax spend some time
with the Tickle Monster so she wouldn't
feel as bad as appealing as that sounded
Eliza didn't want to let her guard down
she felt she owed scp-9999 for keeping
her and the others alive for helping
them forget the horrific world the
foundation had Unleashed and even if she
was the only one she'd protect it night
had fallen the sound of every snapping
twig felt like he could be one of the
scp-610s approaching the rest of the
camp was fast asleep save for Eliza
wielding a flaming branch in one hand to
ward off the flesh sure enough through
the Shadows of the woods and the low
light of her torch she saw shapes began
to shuffle towards her the Slick bloody
creatures looked even worse in the dark
shambling over to Eliza the backing away
cautiously as she brandished her flame
but the flesh that hates was closing in
more and more of them slithering out
from between the trees causing her to
step back in the direction of the camp
suddenly an excitable orange mask swept
past Eliza under the Torchlight she saw
scp-999 approaching the flushing
mutations no she cried out horrified at
what they would do to her Camp's
protector to her surprise the flesh
stopped in their tracks as the Tickle
Monster wriggled up to them they seemed
to get closer examining the orange goop
as it grinned at them then as if they
had lost their innate hostility to
anything that they hadn't yet infected
the scp-610 creatures Turned and Left
perhaps it was something within the
slimy substance the Tickle Monster was
made of that repelled the flesh that
hates or maybe it was because it was
such a sheer force of overwhelming good
and its increased power that allowed
scp-9999 to pacify the monstrosities
either way Eliza breathed eye of relief
the grinning orange blob turned to her
and smiled leaping up into her arms and
allowing her to carry it back to Camp as
scp-999 turned her relief into happiness
once again it seemed that no matter how
Bleak the world might be even in a
timeline as horrifying as that of
scp-5000 wherever the Tickle Monster
goes there will always be the promise of
positivity and with it a sliver of Hope
from the friendliest anomaly of all now
go and check out scp-999 the Tickle
Monster or what if scp-999 War scp-035
for more orange Blobby Adventures